[Music]
my name is max this is my colleague Greg
and we are both program managers on our
billing support team so what do we have
in store for this session well we'll
start with an overview of resource
organization and access management we'll
talk about what that is why it's
important what resources are involved
and how those resources relate to one
another
well then spend some time taking a look
at each resource in a little bit more
detail as well as the key roles that are
necessary to manage those resources and
share some of those key configuration
best practices to think about when
you're actually setting those up well
then take a little bit of time and look
at an example of how the organization of
those resources as well as the role
assignments will evolve over time for an
organization that's growing in size and
then we'll wrap up we don't have a ton
of time to talk to you all today and
cover this content and the detail that
we would like and so we're going to
point you to some key documentation that
we'll go into a lot more detail a lot
more depth that you guys can use with
your teams after the fact now actually
step-by-step go through this process
when you're configuring your accounts
resource organization and access
management it's a bit of a mouthful so
we're just going to refer to this as
resource management for simplicity ok
resource management what is this in the
context of cloud the term resource is
thrown around a lot you've probably
heard it here conference we thought we
felt it would be pretty helpful to
define what we mean by resource and
resource management first by talking
about what we don't in the context of
GCP when when people hear the term
resource they often think of those
service resources that are used to
process your workloads or VMs or
databases all of the underlying products
and services that you consume using GCP
but that's not really what we're talking
about when we talk about resource
management we're talking about the
resources that sit above those services
the ones that are involved and actually
managing and configuring your accounts
such as those easier
now I want to note that we're not
explicitly talking about or looking at
these resources through the lens of cost
management which is you know such as how
you how you can or should be organizing
your various resources your projects
your folders your labels for purposes of
separating out and tracking your various
cost considerations that's a super
important topic and one that's really
well covered by our colleague James in
his session on resource organization for
cost management which he gave yesterday
so if you can get a chance to check that
one out that's totally fine that session
and all the other ones will be available
on YouTube
after that and we highly encourage you
to check that one out because it's
actually a really nice complement do we
want to cover here our purposes in this
session are to give you some
prescriptive guidance on how you should
be thinking about these resources and
the roles that are associated with them
so that you can configure account and
maintain you know good account hygiene
that's really our purpose here so why is
this important
cannot configure an account correctly
can lead to some really common and
problematic states that impact your
team's ability to use GCP you may be
wondering why are we up here you know
from from the support team talking to
you about the count configuration and
resource set up the reason for that is
when customers don't do those things
correctly it often impacts their their
billing their invoicing their payments
and then they reach out to the billing
support team for help so we're really
well positioned to see all the different
ways that this can go wrong
based on the upstream decisions that our
customers are making so we thought we
were in a good place to provide some of
this guidance right now sort of fill in
those gaps when you are making those
decisions to sort of guide you through
done it's pretty telling here actually
that about a third of all the customer
cases the customer inquiries coming into
the billing support team are related in
some way to resource management so it's
super common affects really large
customers and really small customers as
well what's at stake what happens if you
don't do this correctly what can
actually go wrong
these problems with resource management
can manifest in a number of ways ranging
an inability to retrieve information
from your accounts to changing settings
on your resources billing accounts
projects to losing access to those those
resources completely all the way up to
disruption of service and termination of
your account which unfortunately has
actually happened often times though
it's some combination of these things
it's a garbled mess of problems sort of
stack on top of each other and to fix
them requires sort of untangling this
you know ball of yarn so we thought the
best way to address these issues was to
help you avoid them to begin with all
right so let's zoom out a little bit and
take a look at these resources and how
they relate to each other in this
resource Harket starting at the top in
the red boxes we have the domain and the
organization these things collectively
create this sort of umbrella that lets
you more easily manage your users as
well as your resources within the
organization in the green box we have
the billing account which is responsible
for tracking all of your charges that
you're accruing as you use GCP services
and helps define how you pay for those
services in combination with the payment
profile which is the yellow box over
there the left uniquely the payment
profile is not a cloud level resource it
sits outside of that resource hierarchy
and it is responsible for among other
things holding and actually containing
your payment instruments so if you use a
credit card or a debit card that would
reside within your payment profile
lastly we have the blue boxes projects
folders and labels and collectively you
can think of these things is this
flexible mechanism that helps you manage
not only your cost but also your access
to the various underlying services that
you're going to be using all right so
let's dig into these a little bit more I
want to start by noting each of each of
your teams each of your companies is
going to have various considerations
when you're setting up your account and
setting up these resources business
considerations financial legal
organizational that's totally fine those
things are going to influence the way
that you actually you know the decisions
you make when you're actually
configuring and setting this stuff up
what we want to focus on is providing
you with some common best practices and
a general order of opera
that you should be thinking about when
you configure these resources everyone's
going to look different but there are
some you know some common things we want
to encourage you to do in this section
we'll introduce each resource we'll talk
about what are those key configuration
details and best practices are and we
will introduce the core roles that are
necessary to manage each one so let's
start with domains and organizations
like we said together these create this
umbrella under which all of your cloud
resources are nested it helps you manage
those resources and your users these
things are different domains and orgs
but they map on a one-to-one basis so
you can sort of think about them as two
sides of the same coin
a good way to conceptually break these
out is think about domain as the
mechanism to manage your users and the
organization is the mechanism to manage
your resources as well as the access to
the resources
starting with domains in the same way
that your web domain sort of names your
website your met your domain in the
context of cloud names your organization
and it's at this level that you can
define that directory of users you have
within your organization you can enforce
universal policy across those users such
as two-factor authentication and you can
even help your users recover access to
their accounts if they you know lose
access and they need to reset their
password for example all that stuff can
be managed within the Google admin
console when you create a domain that
will automatically create your
organization like I said one-to-one and
we'll talk about how to do that in a
moment on the organization side you can
think about this is that root node in
your GCP hierarchy it's by virtue of
this that you have control all over all
of those subordinate resources that sit
underneath the organ this is really
important for a couple reasons the first
one is proactive management so if your
company is expanding if you're gonna
acquire another company if you're gonna
spin up a new division if you didn't
have a organization you would have to
individually communicate and coordinate
between all the individual resource
owners to achieve some larger vision you
had an organization it makes that really
easy because you can sort of quarterback
those changes from a central point and
that goes really quickly the second
reason it's really important is for
reactive management if you have a really
important project
working on and only a single employee
key employee that's managing that
project and they win the lottery and you
know never come into work again cut out
of luck if you don't have an
organization you have to get in touch
with them you know sort of beg them to
add somebody else to the project yeah
it's kind of a mess if you've had an
organization sort of functions as an
insurance policy allows you to really
easily go back in there and assign that
project to another person on your team
all this stuff with the organization is
related to your GCP resources so
logically you can you can control that
using the GCP console so how do we
create this what do we actually think
about sort of setting this stuff up the
first best practice that we have for you
all is to use a domain and an
organization it's completely voluntary
there's no no no forcing that you have
to forcing you to actually use one of
these things so we want to encourage you
to use it there's not really good reason
not to based on with what we just
discussed so to set up a domain and an
organization you'll start by creating
the domain you have a couple options to
do this you can use G suite or you can
use cloud identity we won't go into the
details of these but you have a couple
options here which is great one of them
is free once you've set that up the next
step will be to provision your users and
you have a couple options here as well
you can do this individually at the
Google admin console or you can use a
tool which we would suggest if you have
a large user base already cloud
directory sync if you want to import a
bunch of users and provision them in
mass once you've set that up you'll sort
of shift focus over to the organization
like we said domain well when you create
your domain will automatically create
your organization so you'll shift over
to that GCP console and you will migrate
any projects that you've been using if
you've happen to be using GCP prior to
setting up your organ projects and
billing accounts here again if you have
a large number of resources that you're
going to be migrating we highly suggest
you use the organization setup wizard to
streamline that process okay lastly so
at this point you'll have your domain
you'll have your org you have users
you'll have your resources
now you're going to sort of connect the
dots and grant permissions for those for
those resources to those users and here
we want to we want to call this out
really important tip by
fault believe the building account
creator rolls on for your organization
for everyone was in it we want to
strongly encourage you to remove that to
turn that off and the reason for that is
it will lead to a proliferation of
billing accounts if you don't do that
and it becomes really problematic you
see a lot of different ways that this
goes wrong it's not really good reason
that to have that turned on you want to
restrict the access to who is able to
create billing accounts because of all
the tie ins to other resources like
payment profiles which we'll discuss in
a moment and it's best to sort of just
get ahead of that and remove it so what
are the key roles involved in setting up
and managing your domain and
organization on the domain side we have
the super admin this person has the
ability to administer that directory of
users they are the person that will
recover accounts if any of your users
lose access get locked out they can
reset those passwords they can also
enforce that sort of domain wide policy
like A to F a and they can grant the
orga Atman the privilege on the other
side with the organisation you have the
organ or gad minh this person has the
ability to administer all of those
resources they're also the individual
that will do that migration that becomes
necessary and it's worth noting that by
default the first domain super admin the
person that actually sets up the domain
will also be the first organ and a
couple of notes on who typically fills
these roles within an organization it
can be very different depending on the
size of the organization when you're
first starting out very common to have
the same individual across both of these
roles someone that has you know IT
responsibilities for your for your team
for your company as organizations get
larger typically we see org admins will
sort of peel off from that it might be
someone more directly involved in the
use of cloud services at your company
could be a CTO had a product and a head
of engineering is anything like that
quick note on roles this applies not
only to the roles we just discussed but
also the ones that we're going to
discuss for the other resources avoid
single points of failure like that
situation that we just talked about with
the employee that wins the lotto and
that never comes back it's a good idea
to assign multiple individuals to these
key roles especially administrator roles
and practice what we're calling
reasonable redundancy that's sort of
half the battle you also want to make
sure that every very other individual
all the other people on your team know
who those administrators are because
they oftentimes have special privileges
and permissions and access within your
company and within GCP and so they sort
of function as this first line of
defense when problems come up they can
help troubleshoot so it's really
important we see this all the time in
larger organizations people don't know
who the billing admin is people don't
know who the the or Gavit is and then
they're coming to support and it creates
this sort of like telephone game it's it
gets pretty pretty complicated and then
lastly we know we know teams change we
know companies evolve people leave and
people come in and so you know sort of
kick the tires on this roles and
permissions list every six months or
every quarter even to make sure that's
up-to-date all right billing counts so
as we said before the billing account is
responsible for containing all of your
your charges tracking all of your
charges from the usage of your GCP
services and it's all those charges that
hit that billing account that ultimately
make its way on to your invoice so
there's one invoice or every billion
account that you have the billing
account also is responsible for defining
how you'll pay for that invoice in
combination with the payment profile
which we'll discuss shortly and like all
of the other resources we're talking
about has its own roles and permissions
and that's that's kind of the core
reason one of the core reasons why
things get really dicey when setting
this stuff up because if you're doing it
in a silo in a way that's not really
paying attention to how you're
configuring or other resources and who
you're putting in those key roles it
creates a lot of confusion within they
don't customers companies also important
to note here that billing accounts can
only operate in a single currency per
billion company so how should you
configure a billing account the first
step is to decide how many billion
counts you need and this is kind of a
trick point because we want to strongly
encourage you to have only a single
billing account that will be appropriate
for the vast majority of our customers
and probably most of the folks in this
room
we see oftentimes customers will use
multiple billing accounts as sort of a
hack for cost management if they want to
separate out costs but we have other
great resources like projects folders
and labels that we should really be
relying on for the heavy lifting for all
of our cost management practices and let
billing accounts kind of just be billing
accounts there are a couple situations
where it does make sense to have
multiple billing accounts if you operate
separate legal entities if you operate
in different geographies and different
currencies in those cases it will make
sense and you will need to have separate
billing accounts but otherwise keep it
to one the reason for that again with a
proliferation of billing accounts it
creates a lot of overhead to make sure
that you're you're tracking things
correctly that you have permission syncs
correctly if you have preferential
pricing you know creates a lot of
problems here so we strongly suggest
keeping one cool all right so first step
is deciding how many you need but also
making sure that it's just one the
second step is defining and creating
them to an account so if you've already
been using GCP you can choose the one
that's going to be the primary one if
you haven't great set up your main one
call that your primary at this point we
want to call out as well turn on or
enable bigquery billing exports on day
one when you when you create your blank
out you can't do this retro actively so
to make sure that you have as much data
as possible you have access to it's
always a good idea to turn on as soon as
you've created the account next you're
going to migrate any resources any
projects specifically over to this
billing account that you may have been
using previously and then lastly you're
going to settle any final balances you
have on older billing accounts you are
no longer planning on using and closing
down we've seen this quite a bit where
customer will have you know a straight
billing account with a single project
attached to it a little bit of usage and
you know the the credit card associated
without one sort of lapses and then it
creates account closure you know
protocols and that has a domino effect
it ends up affecting their other live
billing accounts and so it's really best
to just shut those down if you have any
extra ones and just focus on that
primary billing you
all right key roles in managing your
blanket so the billing account
administrator is going to be the primary
role here this person has the ability to
manage those payment instruments they
can enable bigquery export like we just
talked about is the best practice they
can view costs they can also set up cost
reports or budget alerts which are great
cost management tools that you should be
taking advantage of they can link
projects unlink projects and manage all
of the other users and permissions are
related to that link account really
important here like we talked about
certain administrators of certain
resources have special privileges and
rights and so for the billing account
specifically we require we as in the
billing support team require any
individuals reaching out to us to ask
about a billing account that that person
be a billing account administrator on
that particular account reason for that
is to protect our customers privacy we
don't want to disclose any information
to an individual that wouldn't otherwise
have access to that information so again
make sure that you have multiple
building administrators and also let
everyone know who those people are if
they have a question about billing
they're going to need to funnel that
through the billion ministery we have
another we have another roll up here and
there's there's more than just these two
but we thought these were probably the
most relevant the billing account user
this person a lot more limited in scope
they can basically view costs for the
billing account and they can link
projects into the billing account but
they can't final link them so this role
is often granted in tandem with a
project creator role so it gives
individual the ability to create a
project and then fund that project by
connecting it back in to the to the
billing account oftentimes people and
organizations that we see filling the
billing account administrator role our
folks that are working in finance
accounting
we're oftentimes you know people that
have P&L responsibility for a particular
product line so it could be someone in
product manager alright and with that
I'm gonna pass things over to my
colleague Greg who's gonna talk to us
about payment profiles
all right so thank you max so once again
my name is Greg Guillen and I'm a
program manager on the billing support
team so before we get talking about
payments profiles just a quick show of
hands how many of you have actually
heard of this resource before just a
quick show of hands what about the
Google payment center literally I think
I see like three hands so this is great
this is great because as you can see the
payments profile sits outside of your
GCP resources and you need to understand
why this is important because there's a
huge connection between the payments
profile and the billing account we'll
talk about a why it's important and why
you should be should take note of it so
the payments profile is actually managed
in a completely different console it's
not managing the GCP console if you go
to payments google.com you will actually
see what the payment center looks like I
want to include a screenshot because I
want you all to be very well aware that
the payments profile permissions and
notifications are handled completely
outside of the GCP console there is some
sections that are I framed into the GCP
console changing certain email
preferences but however the majority of
settings should be handled that payments
to Google com so the payments profile is
a Google level resource and what that
means is that you utilize the payments
profile to pay for your Google services
beyond just GCP so you could use your
payments profile to pay for things like
AdWords GCP Chrome Google Play as it's a
Google level resource you are able to
manage different payment methods within
that payment profile so if you're an
online customer you can manage things
such as debit cards credit cards or bank
account information within the payment
Center think of it as a holistic
location to view a lot of your invoices
and documents there's an actual section
called the document Center where you can
see credit memos debit memos and Master
agreements but the thing to take away
from the payments profile is that it is
man is completely separate
outside of your GCP console and I think
a lot of customers are not aware of this
so we'll talk about the implications of
what it means to configure your
payment's profile correctly and how it
can be successful for your organization
so when you're thinking about the
payments profile think of these four
steps to follow our best practices step
1 create a business payments profile a
payments a business payments profile
allows you to go ahead and enter your
tax information we are assuming that
your organization is in business is
treated as a separate legal entity if
you were to create an individual
business payments profile that's are an
individual payments profile you would
not have that functionality but most
importantly is that the business
payments profile allows you to manage a
lot of the permissions and email
notifications for all of your users in
your company that doesn't happen with
the individual payments profile we
recommend that you limit it to one if
possible very similar to billing
accounts what we've seen in billing
support is that whenever customers
create multiple payments profiles and
they call into GCP support it's very
hard to diagnose where the issue lies
and which payment profile in which
billing account right could be the route
or it could allow access to troubleshoot
that issue so we recommend it limit to 1
there are different scenarios where you
would have multiple payments profiles
and we'll walk through those scenarios
later on in the presentation step 2 set
up your payments profile administrator
now we recommend that you mirror this
payments profile administrator to be
your billing account administrator the
exact same permissions if possible for
the reason that I stated is that if you
call into billing support today one of
the ways that we authenticate and verify
you as we verify you is that we asked
you if you are the billing account
administrator now if the issue does lie
with the payments profile it's always
best to ensure that you're the
administrator of both of those resources
so we can troubleshoot the the issue
from end to end step 3 configure users
to receive invoices and account
notifications
we can't stress enough how many times
we've seen fire drills for customers
where you've got someone in accounts
payable and you have someone in in
engineering and they're receiving
different types of notifications based
on the account and when that happens is
there's fire drills within organizations
as to why is my bill not being paid
what's going on how come I can't access
these resources so ensure that everybody
is receiving the right level of
notifications and most importantly can
pay the bill step four at a secondary
payment method so we've seen
historically that you know credit cards
for online accounts credit cards expire
right individuals leave organizations
and in doing so sometimes your GCP
resources do not get paid so we
recommend please add a secondary payment
method so the first one fails you have a
backup for offline accounts also known
as terms or invoice accounts we
recommend that you have a secondary
individual set up as a payments profile
administrator and not only that but you
also take a look login to the center and
you can actually assign individuals
within the organization such as finance
accounting to just receive the invoice
itself we recommend that you review this
every six months you know it's just good
hygiene to have like said we understand
that people go on and do great things
and leave organizations so please just
make sure this information is kept up to
date so the payments profile has two
important roles they should take note of
one is the payments profile Minister
this individual has the keys to the
kingdom this individual can go ahead and
change the actual business name the
legal address different payment methods
change the entire notifications for
everyone receiving invoice information
so it's important that this individual
within an organisation is someone who
usually has senior level visibility into
not only what your organisation is
interacting with Google from a GCP
perspective but across our entire
portfolio of different products like ads
or Google Play or Chrome now if you
don't want to give full access
to user we understand that you have the
option of the read-only access now the
read-only access as a name implies is
just for someone who just needs to see
the invoices just needs to see the
transaction history historically what
we've seen is that individual with this
role will be someone in accounts finance
sorry accounting finance or accounts
payable all right so switching gears to
project folders and labels so as Max had
mentioned before projects folders and
labels are really a flexible mechanism
to help you with your cost management
means it really if they're structured
correctly they help you answer questions
such as how am i spending my GCP
resources today or where can I shift my
resources to get the most use out of GCP
so project folders and labels projects
if you had to think of them think of
them as a bucket and in this bucket it
stores a lot of service level resources
and these service level resources could
be things that could be things such as
kubernetes compute storage and so on now
on top of those projects you have
folders and the folders allow you to
organize your resources in a logical way
well we've seen companies utilizing a
structure perspective is you can
structure your folders to mean things
such as environments so your saging
environment your production environment
or you can even structure them to be
actual teams so your engineering team
your support team etc labels on the
other hand are great for being able to
track your costs across gcpd if applied
correctly they'll allow you to answer a
lot of your fundamental questions as to
how much is application a spending from
a manias perspective or from a
development perspective so we encourage
you to use labels so when setting up
these resources we recommend these four
things one is organize your folders and
priorities projects to mirror your
organization we can't stress enough
please use the naming convention
that works for your organization while I
personally think naming a project cool
writer 87 makes sense you know someone
in finance might not be able to tie that
purchase order to that invoice it might
not be able to make sense of that
project so use something that makes
sense for your organization step to
protect projects that are
mission-critical we appreciate that all
of you have placed a lot of trust onto
GCP to run your mission-critical
projects in order to respect that we've
created a functionality called placing a
lien on a project when you place a lien
on a project it prevents it from
accidental deletion this can be done
through an API call or it can even be
done with through a command-line tool
step 3
add labels for more granular cost
management as we said before if you
apply labels at the right level of
resources you can answer some of the
your most basic questions you can even
answer as to how much our my database
costs how much my incurring from a
database cost perspective across all my
projects or specific to just one project
when creating these resources these GCP
resources we recommend that through the
workflow you actually there's a section
where you can add a label to that
resource early on now if you already
have your hierarchy set up that's ok you
can actually retro actively go back and
apply those labels to those resources
step 4 assign appropriate roles for
folders and projects we recommend that
you use cloud Identity and Access
Management also known as cloud I am so
cloud I am allows you to centrally
manage all of these permissions and
identities and roles all at once as an
administrator it's very difficult to be
applying and removing permissions per
each individual but with cloud I am you
could do it holistically but most
importantly is that cloud I am allows
you for audit and tracking purposes so
for your organization it might be very
important to know who made the changes
who gave individual X X you know Y
permission and so on so it's good from a
security and compliance standpoint
now with project folders and labels we
have two roles one being the project
creator role and the second being the
project editor role as the name implies
the project creator allows you to create
projects this individual will not only
be able to create projects but will also
manage all of the service resources
underneath it at organizations we've
seen that individual with this
permission usually is in charge of
developing the application so it could
be anyone from an engineering lead to
you know a project manager but someone
who has yeah who has access and
visibility into budget cycles and so on
the second role is the project editor
role now if you don't want to give full
permissions of being able to create
projects willy-nilly around the
organization you can go ahead and give
them the project editor role and as the
name implies you can go ahead the
project editor allows you to manage and
edit the resources underneath that
project so this is individual usually at
organizations is someone such as a
developer or a project manager so Max
and I spent a great deal of time talking
about all these different resources
right and we figured that it would be
important to provide some concrete
examples as to how you can follow these
best practices for your organization
we're actually going to walk through a
start-up called digital donut now
digital donut has figured out a way how
to break down donuts into zeros and ones
and send them over the internet
completely revolutionary and they're
making waves so what you see in this
organizational structure is that it's
very basic to follow a startup you've
got one organization one project some
service resources underneath it and a
billing account and a payments profile
and with every startup you've got a
couple of individuals just working
really hard to gain that next customer
and grow the actual business so you have
a founder and developer now the founder
ends up becoming the organ we're going
to
additional admin as was the billon
account admin and payments profile admin
the founder really wanted to let the
developer focus on what they do best and
that's developing the application for
digital donut so as you can see the
developer becomes the project
administrator / owner and this developer
is focused on building the chocolate
application for digital donut so as
digital donut has expanded beyond
markets they started realizing that
there was more of a need than just
chocolate donuts the founder ended up
working with some industry analysts to
go ahead and analyze their customer base
and they found that customers not only
love chocolate donuts but also
jelly-filled doughnuts so as you can see
in this hierarchy you've got project 1
in project 2 because the founder decided
to build out a new product line they
hired an additional developer to become
the project administrator so here you've
separated the responsibilities by
product line the chocolate product line
in the jelly product line so project one
is chocolate project two would be jelly
now the founder has not had a chance to
hire any additional resources so they
remain the org admin as well as the
billing account and payments profile
astray Terr now digital donut has not
only expanded from state to state but
it's just expanding all across the
country and with this expansion as you
can see the organizational structure is
starting to change it's starting to
morph you see the introduction of
folders folder 1 and folder 2 with this
newfound success the founder decided to
hire a CTO this chief technology officer
comes from an organization that has deep
expertise in business-to-business to
handle business and business markets one
of the things the CTO started doing as
they came into the organization was they
wanted to understand and see if digit
donut can move beyond a business to
consumer market and they found that
there was a huge need to sell donuts to
businesses that catering events so
folder 1 will be the business to
consumer
folder two will be the
business-to-business division the
engineer that started out the company
has now moved up the ranks ended up
becoming an engineering lead has a few
folks working under the under them and
becomes the folder administrator as the
folder administrator they have full
rights and access to all the projects
chocolate and glaze underneath that and
all the service level resources
underneath but with that growth into the
new business division we hired an
engineering manager and this engineering
manager is gonna be tasked with building
out the business-to-business division
for digital donut they become the folder
to administrator / owner also with the
success we hired a chief financial
officer as you can see the chief
financial officer becomes the billing
account administrator and the payments
profile admin with this hire the founder
wanted to really understand how am i
spending my DCP resources today I'm
growing out all these different product
lines I need to understand where am i
spending the majority of my development
costs my maintenance cost and so on so
the founder the CTO and the CFO got
together and started applying labels as
you can see labels are being applied at
the product level as well as the service
resource level underneath to measure the
health of digital donut so did your
donut has not only expanded across the
country but now they're looking at
global markets and with these global
markets the founder and all the
leadership started analyzing which
markets would make sense for digital
donuts and they found that there was a
huge need and a huge market in the
European market so as with this instead
of introducing a brand new product they
decided to acquire a company who had a
similar business model Digital croissant
now digital croissant was a great
acquisition because they also use GCP
services and with that they brought
their own leadership team their own CTO
their own engineering leads and managers
now we discuss that in some slides back
we discussed that there was certain
scenarios where it would make sense
where you would have multiple billing
accounts and multiple payment profiles
and here's that example because Digital
donut functions in a US currency and has
its own legal entity it has its own
billing account payments profile but
digital croissant is function in a
European market they're gonna be having
their own tax code and acting as its own
legal entity they're going to be
receiving separate documents separate
invoices so it makes sense to have this
structure today but as you grow as an
organization's with every mergers and
acquisitions we recommend that
eventually you start merging a lot of
these organizations and folders and
resources that make sense to your
organization for the reason that it
helps from a cost management perspective
from a security and permissions aspect
as well now with that cotton solid ation
we noticed that the payments profile and
billing account had no administrators
during this mergers and acquisition so
we brought over our chief financial
officer to also become the billing
account - and payments profile to
administrator so what we wanted to do is
provide some concrete examples of how to
follow our best practices that we both
mentioned today now we understand that
these examples might not mirror your
organization and that's okay we
understand that but we want to do is
just provide you as many resources as
possible and as many concrete examples
as possible to make your organization
successful so I'm gonna go ahead and
pass it off back to max thank you all
right so we covered a bunch of stuff
today from domains organizations doing
accounts payments profiles projects
folders and labels so we wanted to
consolidate all of the best practices
and tips that we had we're sort of
interest bursts throughout all of that
so we created the slight goodness you
can take photos of all right yeah if you
know if you came in here with the best
of intentions you got your seats you got
your paper and your
your tablet may be ready to take some
notes and then you immediately fell
asleep and heard nothing that we said
the entire time that's okay
first off good on you it's a pretty
pretty boss move if I respect that a
second of all that's fine because
everything that we talked about and more
we included in a guide guide to resource
organization and access management so we
want to strongly encourage you if you do
one thing you take one thing away from
today check this out
gogo here when you have some time after
next in the next week next couple weeks
with your team with with the core folks
that are likely going to be in those
administrative positions that we
discussed and walk through this wisdom
we have a checklist on each of the
resources that we go into a lot more
detail we have a lot of extra links on
you know additional information and
references for all of the resources and
sort of the guides and decisions key
decisions that you need to make so
please check this out and go through
that
[Music]